hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in Chapter 13 of his work on controlling
anger Plutarch is going to give us some
really great advice about one way that
we can gradually begin to wean ourselves
away from anger and that is by
cultivating a life that is fairly simple
where we can be content without having
too much or certain kinds of things
because when we are very attached to
getting things the way that we want them
to be particularly if it requires a lot
of effort or luck to get them that way
we are setting ourselves up for getting
angry and he talks about four conditions
in particular that tend to produce anger
in us and these are all worth dwelling
on a bit so the first one is selfishness
fill out here in Greek and which
literally means a Love or liking of
One's Own Self so selfishness in the
sense of wanting the best things for you
as opposed to other people or
prioritizing yourself over other people
perhaps when you shouldn't because you
know there are legitimate times to
prioritize yourself and to love yourself
but that doesn't mean that you have to
deprive others or ignore the needs of
others then he talks about what's
translated as peevishness we would
translate it as being a Debbie Downer or
being you know easily upset or irritable
Deuce Julia right this sense of like
getting upset over very trivial things
and and that being one's disposition
luxury through Fae and softness malakia
these two kind of go together it's you
know these these are a sense of needing
things to be very pleasant for oneself
you know you need not just a tie but the
very fancy tie that is made from the
better silk or you know is a designer
product or something like that and then
softness is an incapacity to stand up
against the things that are painful or
demanding that require endurance of us
so you know softness could be displayed
and how one does one's work or what one
can endure can you go outside in Winter
and just put your hands in your pockets
without needing special gloves for
yourself right now if we if we have
these conditions we're likely to get
angry much more easily because we're
living in a world where we're not going
to get things our way all the time
especially if what we want is kind of
irrational
on the other side as he says gentleness
towards others whether he says there's
nothing more conducive to gentleness
right and not just to any old others but
to friends and neighbors and one spouse
the people that one is going to spend a
lot of time with is promoted by other
dispositions for example graciousness
eucholia or another way of translating
it as is done in this version
contentment being content being good
with others and simplicity is also very
important athelias in Greece which
literally means like not having stones
in in the field being a simple smooth
kind of person right and so when you
have these in place of you know
selfishness or the need for luxury or
peevishness well then you're going to be
inclined towards the opposite of anger
the virtue of gentleness or mildness
proud taste and Plutarch says that
what's really essential to this is being
able to get by with literally what one
has this translation is kind of uh
interesting it says being able to get
along with what Comforts one but the
Greek is actually
um
being capable
right the things that are at hand so you
know if you've got fancy wine well you
drink the fancy wine but if you've got
you know cheap wine drink the cheap wine
it's just as fine there's no wine drink
some water or whatever else is on hand
so being being able to get by with what
one has and the you know the sort of the
flip side of that is not being in need
of a lot of things that are kind of
unimportant right uh May Deo Mano so
Deon is to be in need of so not to need
a whole bunch of it's translated here is
super flurries right the things that are
non-essential what do you need you need
some you know clothing you need some
food you need some shelter you need in
our days you know some access to the
internet might be a basic need but you
don't really need a lot of fancy stuff
and if you're dependent on that then
you're going to get yourself angry and
he gives some great examples of people
who are a little bit precious in this
respect he talks about
well he quotes this this great line but
he who liked his meat not overdone nor
underdone nor medium no nor boiled too
much and like no food enough to praise
who will drink no wine if there is no
snow in it what does that mean he wants
his wine chilled right snow should be
brought down from the mountaintops into
places where we'll store the wine nor
will he eat bread purchased in the
market nor to touch food served on
cheaper earthenware dishes nor sleep on
a bed that does not Bill like the sea
stirred to its depths so lots of pillows
and blankets and stuff like that he who
with rods and blows makes his servants
at table hasten about running and crying
out and sweating as though they are
bringing poultices for boils such a man
he says is enslaved to an impotent
querulous and discontented mode of Life
they demand all these luxuries they
demand things to be the way that they
want them you know they they want it to
be their way they're selfish in that
respect they can't let things slide and
so they're going to get real upset and
he talks about you know the many shocks
of anger being like a chronic cough by
which he reduces himself to a condition
where anger becomes a running sword he's
become habituated to being demanding and
then getting angry as a result and so
this leads to some other advice about
how we should habituate ourselves in a
different way you know or become
accustomed ethy stay on this is the we
ought to or one ought to become
accustomed or habituated to to what
habituating the body
through a simple life
if we do this then we are going to be
much light much more likely to be calm
what is going to result from this
contentment eocolia or the contentment
that we want to show towards others and
most importantly
self-sufficiency for the ancient
greeksa self-sufficiency was viewed as
an incredibly important value not being
dependent upon others upon random things
working out but being able to suffice
onto oneself makes you less angry and he
uses as examples of this eating and
drinking so he says to begin with our
food it's no great hardship if we
partake in Silence of whatever is set
before us and do not by being repeatedly
irritated and peevish thrust Upon Our
ourselves and our friends the worst
sauce for meat anger so you know when we
get fed our food we should just eat it
and don't say anything about it don't
get picky don't get whiny don't get
irritated don't expect it to be a
certain way just put it in your mouth
and eat it up right and he goes out and
he says I mean people beat their
servants and you know revile their wives
because something is burned or smoked or
not salted enough or because the bread
is too cold this is trivial stuff that
we should not allow to get to us he goes
on as well and says
you know we should accustom ourselves to
make cheerful use of any kind of table
utensils and not to prefer this service
to that as do some people who prefer one
goblet or one chalice to another there's
no need to be so picky there's no need
to be so particular if you need to drink
water you can drink it out of a stone
mug you can drink it out of Crystal
you're still drinking water and you
don't need to get worked up about that
he says and this is sort of a segue into
thinking about something else anybody
who's prone to anger here's something
that they should do they should refrain
or hold back literally from anything
that's rare and precious why should they
do this because if they lose it like the
person who's got their favorite mug and
they gotta drink out of that mug
it's not going to be easy to replace
whereas if you know you have no problem
drinking out of a plastic Solo Cup and
that's fine for you you lose it you just
get another one right you're not going
to be upset but if you tie yourself in
with needing things to be a certain way
you know whether it's a fork or a cop or
you know your table mat or you need to
listen to special music while you're
eating you're going to be setting
yourself up for all sorts of anger
problems and he gives the example of
Nero and Seneca Nera had this massive
tent built and it was a very beautiful
and Seneca said well bad idea buddy
you've proven yourself a poor man
because if you ever lose this you're not
going to be able to get another one and
uh it did so happen like he says that
the ship which conveyed it was sunk on
the tent loss but Nero remembered Seneca
saying and bore his loss with greater
moderation so if we can practice this
this is a way for us to keep ourselves
from getting angry over trivial things
we need to you know aim at
self-sufficiency at Simplicity and not
demanding too much and try to avoid
selfishness peevishness luxury and
softness and if we can do that if we can
prune that out of our Lives we will be
calm or gentle rather than inclined to
anger